,
t'es bon à marier, hein!
- Oui, c'est pour ça que n n n t
plus partir : sa bouffe est
trop bonne!
- Charlotte Aubin, vous incarnez
le personnage de Jade hahahahahe
qui vous colle à la peau et qui
vous suit depuis six ans déjà.
Je pense que ça a complètement
changé votre c r r r r r r r r ?
CHARLOTTE AUBIN, comédienne
- Bien oui, vraiment, puis
je venais tout juste de sortir
de
ce rôle-là. Puis, c'est drôle
de grandir avec un personnage
aussi. T'sais, je me vois
comme interprète aussi qui prend
ou qui se définit, puis là,
de voir un personnage évol
avec moi, je trouve ça vraiment
formidable, en fait.
dans la rue pour vous en parler
tout le temps.
- Oui, vraiment, puis là,
il y a comme une espèce de saga
dans l'émission. Les gens sont
bien inquipopopour moi, là.
(rires)
- Sérieusement?
super touchant! C'est comme,
je pense que les gens fo
la différence entre la fiction
puis la réalité, mais c'est un
aussi. T'sais, c'est comme
la candeur, la généros
la douceur... Ça fait que
les gens, ils ne veulent pas
à ce personnage-là.
- OK, on va se reculer.
- J'ai fouillé dans nos archives
et j'ai trouvé des images
du tapis rouge de"."."."."."."..
- Oh my God!
usususus aviez 15 ans.
- Oui, j'avais 15 ans.
- Premier rôle.
- Quels souvenirs vous gardez
de cette époque-là? Parce
tout a commencé là pour vous.
- Oui, absolument.
Bien, en fais s s s s s s s s s;
à ce moment-là, j'étais très,
très, très candide. Je me suis
inscrite à des auditions
j'aimais le théâtre,
çaesesesesessait, le cinéma puis
tout ça. Puis je me rendais pas
compte du gros proa a a a a a ai
était autour de ce film-là.
C'est une expérience formidable.
J'ai rencontré des gens avec qui
dont Pierre Mignot, le directeur
photo. Ça a été une grande
rencontre aussi avec Jeanne
Mo
rencontre qui m'a beaucoup
appris sur le jeu,
m'a appris aussi comment être
une femme dans ce métier-là.
- Oui, je trouve...- Et commente
dans ce métier-là?
- Je trouve qu'elle, eisisisisi.
Puis je pense que c'est
des choses que j'essaie d'avoir
moi aussi, une espèce de goût du
travail, un ucucucucucucucucucus
aussi beaucoup de malléabilité,
de délicatesse, d'écoute
de l'autre. Ça fait que oui,
je peneleleleleleleleleleleleles
que j'ai faites par la suite.
Mais c'était comme une bonne
mentor pour commencer, mettons.
Charlotte Aubin, "élégance"
et "chien". C'est ça?
- J'aimerais ça que le monde
dise ça, oui.
- Oui.
- OK.
- Mais... comme une espèce
d'intensité, mais habillée
de délicatesse, mettons.
- Toute jeune, vous rêviezdeded.
- Oui.
- Mais vous étiez auss
de l'âge de 4 ans à 16 ans,
vousioioioioioioiolon.
- Oui.
- En quoi le jeu et la musique
- Bien, je pense que ça donne
memememememement une rigueur,
là, t'sais, je pense que
de 4 à 16 ans, il fallaieueueuee
par jour. Ça fait que ça donneu,
je trouve que dans la musique,
puis dans rendre un ioioioioioia
comme... il faut se mettre
dans le point de vue de l'auteur
ou du compositeur. Puis je pense
qu'il y avai s s s s s s s s s u
dans l'esprit, dans l'époque.
Puis je pense que c'est la même
chose aussi au théâtre ou au
la vision de l'auteur,
du réalisateur. Ça fait que
je pense que tout ça est connexe
au bout du compte.
mais j'ai l'impression que ça
fait peut-être partie
chose qui est intrinsèque
ou instinctif maintenant.
a été mise à l'épreuve
dans la série "V
où vous incarniez Frédérique,
inspirée du parcours de Marianne
préparation monstre pour enfile!
Je pense que vous vous êtes
entraî- - - - - - - - - - - - -.
Ça a été vraiment trssssssss
intense, mais j'étais seulement
là-dedans. Je faisais rien
je n'ai que pensé à ce rôle-là,
bâti mon corps pour ce rôle-là,
puis quand je suis arrivée la
je me sentais... Bien, je me
sentais prueueueueueueueue j'avs
travaillé beaucoup en amont.
Oui, j'ai vraiment commecocococs
pouvait être un atout,
pouvait se transformer.
Moi, j'accepterais de prendre
de devenir musclée comme t t t .
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
dans êststststststststststststs,
là, on a envie vraimen
l'autre, de devenir l'autre.
Puis avec ce personnage-là,
jusqu'au bout. Ça fait que oui,
on dirait que... Bien, je suis
fière de moi. C'est peut-être
mais je suis fière de
cette prépar
- Vous êtes fan de cinéma,
cinéma indépendant.
- Vous êtes justement la porte-
parole du festival Regard...
- Oui!
de Saguenay. J'imagine que ça,
dedededededededededeau pour vous
en 2022?
- Ah oui! c'est un honneur.s
contente. Puis j'ai faitupupupu.
C'est comme super important
pour moi dans mon parcPuPuPuPuPs
ce festival-là, c'est mythique!e
aux courts métrages au Québec
qui est fou u u u u u u u u u u.
J'ai tout le temps été prise
à Montréal pour le travail
ou quoi que ce soit.
Ça re fois là-bas et
en plus, je suis porte-parole.
C'est bien excitant!
- Cette entrevue a lieu dans un,
où vous devez jouer peut-
dans les prochaines semaines?
- Oui...m m m m m m m m m m m m,
mais version Catherine Léger, ùn
de la femme. J'imagine que
vous avez hât t t t t t t t t te
fois que c'est reporté en plus;r
ce spectacle-là! Il est prêt,
c'est eneneneneneneneneneneneneu
formidables.
Ça fait qu'on croise les doigts.
Ça serait vraiment le fun
qu